congratulations someone told me today
it's been 25 years that you've been
doing stand-up comedy that's right I
don't know how or I didn't I didn't get
any better
no better you the same now 25 years ago
I am I used to come on I didn't remember
anything you know I would always would
freak out and look at people and say and
then start talking about not what I
meant
and then they stayed and 25 years thank
you thank you very much I made it yeah
like this is it now you're gay I'm
waiting for someone to come along with a
clock and a cup and a package holiday a
caravan maybe yes see there's nothing
like that in comedy you could do 25
years if you worked in a bank they'd
give you a gold watch something they'd
give you something you have something
that doesn't happen in this business no
you couldn't I have some laundry
receipts and I know you can buy Doritos
pretty much anywhere but that's it
that's it that's all you can Det well
let's talk about things I'm curious
about for example st. Patrick's Day the
United States they make such a big deal
you're out of it and I know that the
tradition in Ireland is is quite
different what did you do on st.
Patrick's Day did you go do you go crazy
witch witch would know the two
traditions in Ireland's are very simple
you people have some sandwiches and they
they're hanging around because it's a
holiday and then the other tradition is
you take your top off and you get onto a
roof in your challenged whole population
centers to a fight and I didn't do that
because I'm having a holiday from booze
so how long is your holiday from booze
well I did dry January which is the
thing people do a lot in ireland britain
and i lost 485 pounds really is that
really quite popular that people do a
drive it's not a choice people don't do
it because they know this is a healthy
lifestyle choice they do it because
they're about to die yeah make those
choices they do it against their will
are you finding it with without drinking
in your life do you feel like there's
more you can accomplish there's more you
can do I know there's certainly more I
can experience because days are so
incredibly long 385,000 hours in
with us 385,000 hair is say you can
check it's great if you're a fan of you
uh-huh if you're a fan of yourself yeah
because you get to have much more
uninterrupted time of your own
consciousness yes what I found that gets
a bit wearisome after about our 389 yeah
but it does maybe explain why Trump is
famously teetotal yeah there's a guy who
loves him
he likes to be with him he wants to
spend more time with Donald you think
that that's doesn't drink yes because he
wants to do alone time with him that's
right he wants a concentrated experience
of pure Trump off city so he does with
any booze I love that theory I want to
attain that theory
you